at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode of the Tim Ferriss
show is brought to you by 99 designs and
ex-officio 99 designs is the world's
largest online marketplace of graphic
designers and I have used 99 designs for
years including to get cover concepts
for the 4-hour body which went on to
become number one New York Times number
one Wall Street Journal it was a huge
hit and here's how it works
and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions you
can see these book covers and so on at
99 designs com forward slash Tim whether
you need a logo a car app a web design
an app a thumbnail a t-shirt whatever
you go to 99 designs calm you describe
your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around
the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs
and drafts you have an original design
that you love or you pay nothing it is
fantastic I have used it I have
mentioned it before including in the
4-hour workweek as a resource check it
out 99 designs com forward slash Tim and
if you use that link you'll be able to
see what I've done on the platform you
will also get $99 as an upgrade for free
which will get you more designs more
submissions so check it out
ex-officio boy where do I begin I have a
long history with ex-officio ex-officio
makes clothing and as far back as 2007
2008 I had a hit video that went viral
called how to travel the world with 10
pounds or less and I talked about
ex-officio underwear ex-officio
underwear is lightweight ultra
lightweight quick drying and
antimicrobial why is this important well
I've gone through 20 plus countries with
two pairs of underwear before both from
ex-officio and I'm not alone in this
this might sound crazy but a lot of
executives for instance will take this
underwear they'll wash it in the sink or
somewhere else roll it up in
towel like a burrito step on it and a
few hours later they are completely dry
completely clean you don't have to just
have to and yes they have to be
comfortable for all-day wear but check
out their clothing as well as their
underwear you can go to ex-officio comm
forward slash Tim that's X DX o FF I
cio.com forward slash Tim and you can
see this video which has a bunch of
other packing tips but this underwear
this clothing is not just for the gents
ladies you have choices too and they
really have an incredible collection of
high quality products that I've used for
almost 10 years now so check them out ex
officio com forward slash Tim hello my
two munchkins
this is Tim Paris and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show it is
late at night I'm in Boston back on the
East Coast for a beautiful beautiful
fall day or I should say evening it is
probably close to 1:00 a.m. and I just
finished up some work with build org if
you are an entrepreneur you gotta check
him out Bildad org but to our subject
matter at hand
Ralph Potts Roth pots off pots Roth pots
Roth box
I'm in the Halloween spirit and I'm
attempting to summon Ralph's pots to my
hotel room like candy man but it's not
working and why would I do such a thing
anyway I would do that because Ralph's
pots is hilarious and he is one of my
favorite writers and this episode
showcases his intelligence and his wit I
think one of the quotes for instance is
war is God's Way of teaching Americans
geography this guy is hilarious and he's
also a very astute observer of human
nature and a master world traveler among
other things he is the author of several
books including vagabonding invaluable
in vagabonding vagabonding has a very
important place in my life I sound like
the the science duck modeled after
Albert Einstein I'm gonna run with that
but I won't subject you to that horrible
imitation for the entire BIOS so Rolf
Potts road bag
vagabonding is a very important book in
my life it is one of two books the other
being Walden by Thoreau that I took with
me when I left the US and ended up
travelling nearly 18 months around the
world in 2004 and of course all of those
experiences set the stage for later
writing 4-hour workweek all the notes
that I took and vagabonding had a huge
impact on my thinking and how I
approached all of that time and it was
initially a four-week trip it turned
into 18 months so vagabonding is an
incredible book so much so that I
partnered with Ralph very recently to
produce the audiobook because it is one
of my favorite books of all time you can
check that out by going to
audible.com/veritasium Travel long term
world travel does not have to be a
wealthy person sport and in this
conversation we talk about all sorts of
things ranging from how to travel how
Rolf travels writes wanders gets lost
studies success studies quitting success
or managing success and maybe you
haven't thought that's an important
element of life planning but it
apparently is I've come to believe and I
almost forgot of course there are a ton
of resources and links and websites and
books mentioned in this episode all of
it can be found in one place in the show
notes so you just have to go to 4-hour
workweek com all spelled out forward
slash podcast 4-hour workweek com
forward slash podcast you can find the
show notes and resources and links for
this episode as well as every other
episode like those for Peter teal Tony
Robbins Mike Shinoda you name it so you
don't need to scribble furiously unless
you want to
but 4-hour workweek dot-com forward
slash podcast is where you want to go
and I had a blast with this interview it
is a two-part interview this is gonna be
part one and then there's part two and I
really hope you enjoy it as much as I
did it was just fantastic fun so without
further ado please meet Ralph
hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show I am very
excited for this episode because I get
to catch up with a good friend of mine
who didn't start off as a good friend
and that is Rolf Potts
Rolf thank you so much for making the
time it's good to talk to you yeah and I
and I realized by saying that you didn't
start off as a good friend it makes it
sound like we might have been
archenemies or something but what I mean
by that is I really felt like I got to
know you through your book vagabonding
which was one of two books many people
do not know this that I took with me
around the world for about a year and a
half starting in late 2004 early 2005 it
must have been 2004 and I it is one of
my most heavily underlined books and
really acted as my guide and my
companion for all of the various travels
adventures misadventures
during that time so first and foremost
thank you for writing such a spectacular
little tome my pleasure thank you for
reading you know it occurs to me that I
heard from you in late 2005 which was in
retrospect was pretty soon after I had
written the book so you must have found
it
pretty soon after it came out yeah I
found it I found it I found it soon
after it came out because I suppose in
this this may be true for many people
the the buying of the book then the
reading of the book and then the
implementing of the book quite a bit of
lag time in between those various
junctures and but I think like a lot of
people I was really I spend a lot of
time fantasizing about travel and taking
that leap but had more than handful of
nebulous fear about it
and I suppose we could start there
actually and and I could ask very simply
what are some recommendations that you
have for people who may be able to
work up the savings if necessary and are
really just fearful of taking the leap
and exploring long term travel and I
suppose just wrapped into that you might
give a brief description of vagabonding
itself and the subtitle and and and then
why you wrote it but I'll let you
explore that multi-part question if you
wouldn't wouldn't mind yeah well I like
that you bring up the idea of
fantasizing about travel because I think
it's something that everybody does and
it's one of those top three if not top
two or one things that people dream
about that and you see it in the movies
all the time and in fact I mentioned
this in Baga bonding you know the heist
movie where the whole goal is to have
this complicated robbery so they can
have enough money to move overseas to a
wonderful place and as I say in the book
is you don't need a rob a bank to do
that in fact you can do that for a cost
that is equal to and sometimes less than
your cost of living in a major American
city and so I think an important
principle I bring up in vagabonding is
saying don't don't put this off if
you're dreaming about travel and most
people do and if you know and if you
don't remember travel that's fine but I
really address these travel dreams which
are so common that don't wait until you
tell you're too old because you know
retirement isn't necessarily the best
time to to do something like this and in
fact Henry David Thoreau I think Walden
was the other book you took on your
travels right talks about how people and
I'm not quoting him directly they you
know they put off what they really want
to do until they're too old to actually
do it you know that's a paraphrase and
so if you are 1828 you know 3848
whenever you're dreaming about travel
put make your goals soon and and don't
put off those goals because they're very
attainable and you know I think there's
a lot of fears that are tied in to
confronting vagabonding which you asked
me if the for the definition its value
my name is long-term travel it's not
just a vacation it's not a week or two
off that you know society gives you as a
vacation it's six months or two years or
you know six weeks
you make for yourself to travel in
earnest not as a consumer experience not
as a vacation but as you know a more
deeply meaningful life experience and as
a way to actualize your wealth of time
and I think this is an idea we'll come
back to a lot and it's something that
you write about as well as me is the
idea of tying wealth the idea that your
experiences are more valuable in life
than the the things that you accumulate
and the things that are always being
touted as the most important things in
life so travel is a great way to cash in
on your time wealth and and vagabonding
just by definition is a more meaningful
way of travel it's a way of slowing down
and really discovering parts of yourself
instead of just buying a lot of
experiences which is which we've sort of
been conditioned to do as American
consumers my first vagabonding trip was
20 years ago this year
oddly enough and happy Anniversary thank
you thank you it was just this time that
I was that I was straggling back to
Kansas after having this amazing
eight-month trip around North America
and it was a trip that I thought would
be my last I thought I would get travel
out of my system so I could become a
responsible American workaholic and then
maybe return to travel when I was old
but you you mentioned the idea of fear
and the fears I had going out were you
know is this gonna be expensive it's
gonna is this gonna be dangerous am I
gonna come back and be compromised
professionally and all of those sort of
turned into the into the opposite that
it was a lot safer than I expected it
was a lot cheaper than I expected and I
came back and for 20 years I've been
integrating travel with with a
professional life that continues to
diversify I continue to to to do other
things to make money well at the same
time having big swathes of time to
travel and I'm not suggesting that
everybody needs to you know become a
vagabond or for a 20 year chunk and in
some ways I travel a lot less than I
used to you know 10 or 15 years ago but
it's something that you can do it's an
option that you can have and it's it's
not an action an option that you wait
for life to give you you create it and
so I'm a big believer in the active
aspect of vagabonding of saving your
money but
lottery is another metaphor I use a lot
in vagabonding that people keep waiting
for the lottery to reward them but as we
all know the odds that you're gonna win
the lottery is pretty low but you've
already won the lottery we're born with
time wealth and so it's just a matter of
creating these travel experiences or
these time rich experiences through
things like simplicity and just the
decision to make these sort of things
happen well that's I one of the themes
and I think gifts that you provide and
vagabonding and for those perhaps
wondering this the subtitle says a lot
which is an uncommon guide to the art of
long-term world travel and I think
uncommon in art or both keywords in that
subtitle you provide a a a portfolio it
sounds to financial yeah a quiver of
philosophies and suggestions for
simplification viewing the world through
a different lens really decluttering
your life both materially and
emotionally and psychologically even if
you do not travel and what I've noticed
is it I recommend vagabonding to people
who have no intention of traveling or
for whatever set of circumstances feel
they can't travel simply because and I'm
blanking on the attribution here but I
really believe that most people even
those who have more money than they know
what to do with live lives of quiet
desperation and they have this they've
they've fallen into a drone-like
schedule where they have these material
objects they thought might make them
happy or give them something they were
lacking beforehand but they've lost that
the excitement and anticipation perhaps
that they once had you know the the the
leaping into the unknown the the the the
feeling that kids have the night before
Christmas or the week before Christmas
and adults lose that nothing one of the
easiest ways to capture that
is to actually fantasize about travel
but do it in detail it's not one day I
want to travel but to read vagabonding
oh my god like I could do a I could do B
I could go to Japan for the first time I
could go to Europe and busk I could do
all of these things that that rekindle
that passion and enthusiasm and
excitement because I think that
excitement is a much more tangible
metric for perhaps what other otherwise
can be very nebulous in the word
successful right and in the u.s. I think
that for better or for worse and I think
perhaps for both we have this in a
Protestant like work ethic towards a
relatively undefined goal which is this
this success and what are some exercises
just in terms of helping to address that
fear so you mentioned one thing which
would be setting a near time horizon for
travel right and I completely agree that
the in many ways the utility of travel
decreases as your physical capacity
decreases right so you can do the most
you have the most options the younger
you are when you travel or at least the
the more functional your body is when
you travel
aside from setting a tight goal and
whether that's you know a few weeks away
a few months away what are some extra
are there any exercises that people can
go through to decrease that fear factor
and or anything they can read but
besides vagabonding to decrease that
fear factor and their their stories for
instance that I'll tell folks about
Colombia is a good example so I recently
not too long ago spent a month in MIDI
in Colombia which was formerly the
murder capital of the world
when it was under the the Iron Fist of
Pablo Escobar that the drug kingpin and
I I
I feel more threatened on Market Street
in San Francisco on a daily basis
whenever I go home and walk down certain
portions of Market Street then I ever
felt in MIDI and I went all throughout
the entire city
and you know I think that sometimes the
stories can be helpful but do you have
any recommendations for whether it's
exercises or things to read to sort of
overcome the fear of the the big bad
overseas adventures and all the terrible
things that await you or not yeah well
there's a couple of big picture ones
it's funny Medi and I was I was just
there a year and a half ago and I think
now it's like the breast augmentation
capital of the world yeah it's yeah you
know South America is it's like the you
know I guess Korea has its facial
bleaching and then you know South
America has if you Brazil there's the
button plant capital of the world which
is still incredible just to even ponder
but yes continue sorry to interrupt
right now the drug lords moved out and
the plastic surgeons moved in it's a
beautiful city but that was just it was
a strange like physical attribute that
it's that's obviously a surgeons have
been hard at work wonderful City the
advice the advice that I have there's a
couple of big picture ones the big
picture advice that I have for this and
one is two they're both sort of mental
they're about redefining your
relationship or just how you think about
things one is your relationship to money
and what it represents and one is your
relationship to information and what it
represents
you mentioned success you know the idea
of the American you know puritanical
idea of what success is and money is a
great metric for success but it's not
the only metric for success and I think
people fixate on money to their own
detriment because I meant as I mentioned
before it doesn't take that much money
to travel the world travel isn't a
consumer experience and I think you you
said you weren't sure the reference I
think you're recording through when
you're sort of talking about these rich
people who were sort of bound by their
own riches and he's he's actually
stealing that from the Bible and in the
old Hindu scriptures which talk about
these these golden chains with you know
under which we sink you know we're bound
to our possessions and through success
it is a very old philosophical idea
through success we lose perspective on
on the good life because we tie success
so closely with money and possessions
and and material splendor and so if you
can if you can just redefine your
relationship with what success is and
and and really goes back to the idea of
time wealth that success is being able
to do what you want whenever you want
and there's billionaires out there who
are compromised in ways that you or I or
you know your plumber or your local park
ranger or not because just realizing
that money is a tool it's not a metric
for success it's a nice side product of
success but it's a tool for allowing you
to live a time rich and experienced rich
life and really live in ways that allow
you to not only follow but discover
passions that you never realized you had
no I I agree on so many levels and just
just to because of course the we both
think about this stuff a lot and I
apologize for jumping in but the the
just on the billionaire point to give
some concrete examples so the the this
is very recent I was talking to a fellow
he is putting together an event it's
going to be 20 or 30 people a number of
billionaires in attendance and it's a
week-long retreat of sorts and and he
said to me and this is a very this this
actually that the gentleman is
organizing it is very materially
successful but actually has a very level
head on his shoulders and has been able
to keep things like time and mobility in
mind as as important currencies and
metrics for his quality of life so he's
done a really good job but he said of
course the billionaires can't take a
week off so they're only going to be
there for 24 to 36 hours and I thought
about that and it was like the
billionaire's can't take a week off what
the hell is the point of having their
billion dollars if they can't if they
don't have the options if they have
fewer options than I do if that makes
sense and it reminded me of a
conversation I had at one point with
another person who shall remain unnamed
but he has at least several hundred
million dollars maybe a billion plus
and he was commenting on the number of
homes that he had and he's a good guy
but the in effect his accumulation had
gotten so out of control in the end
between six and twelve homes around the
u.s. and he said I know I no longer feel
like people work for me I feel like I
work for them because he has staff of
five to ten people at each of these
homes he's never at nine out of ten of
them and so he's effectively just
working to pay for homes where his staff
basically are the owners of the homes
because they live here and I was like
wow it really brings to mind a this is
also a quote of course I don't know the
the the attribution but the the idea
that things in excess become their
opposite right so you know money that
provides you with freedom basically
takes away your freedom when it's when
it when it reaches a certain point it
starts to reduce your freedom the idea
that the so-called freedom fighters in
in excess you know given too much power
become tyrants right so things tend to
flip when they get to a certain point of
access what and also just because I'm
such a die-hard fan boy of vagabonding
correct me if I'm wrong but the example
that I think you gave in vagabonding of
sort of Hollywood nonsense related to
overseas travel was from Wall Street
wasn't it from Wall Street where the the
Charlie Sheen's big goal was to save up
enough money you know one day when he
strikes it big to to get a motorcycle
and drive a car across China I think
yeah and you pointed out that you could
scrub toilets in China not even in the
US for a month or two and probably
figure out a way financially to make
that possible so certainly I mean when I
was traveling
and ultimately putting together the
notes and observations that became the
4-hour workweek I saved tens of
thousands of dollars compared to simply
staying in the Bay Area in California
and anyway just that's the thing is that
if you live in in an expensive city like
like San Francisco New York there's
probably a half dozen other examples in
the United States alone you're gonna be
living on fewer dollars per day by far
if you're traveling in Southeast Asia or
South America or the Middle East then
you would just be paying your bills and
paying your rent and buying your
groceries at home that you're you're
traveling in a completely different
economic zone which was sort of the
point of pointing out this Wall Street
example and China that was that movie
was from the 80s certainly China is more
expensive since then you might not have
to clean toilets you might have to clean
something else now that to ride your
motorcycle across China but the point is
is that you know all this importance is
placed upon conspicuous consumption a
romantic ideas of what we can do and
oftentimes it's not money that's in the
way it's it's a mindset thing which is
why I'm sort of answering your question
your earlier question a big-picture way
that it's it's really a mindset about
your relationship to money and your
relationship to information which I'll
get to in a second but you were talking
about you know the billionaire who sort
of become a slave to his own parasitical
wealth that's an old idea too I have a
quote from the ancient Sanskrit
scriptures in vagabonding which is about
the king and his palace only has half a
bed and the food on his plate for all
the grain in his fields does he own the
rest you know right at the end of the
day even the kings and I knew this 3,000
years ago even Kings only eat one meal
at a time they only sleep in one bed at
a time and at the end of the day the
substance of your life is through
experience and if you're suddenly
compromised your material wealth and
your money is is there to actualize your
experience and and you know to enhance
your life meaning and the moment that it
becomes parasitical the mome
you're a billionaire who has 36 hours to
go to a conference and I'd love to know
how much money is spent flying to the
conference catering it you know because
you know I know people who could travel
probably for five years on what 1
billion are spends to go to that 36 hour
conference and I'm sure you know people
who could do the same so that's just
such an important thing to keep in mind
is to I have nothing against success or
material success but really know where
the line is
the point at which the success you have
achieved is actually getting into the
way of actual izing a good and
meaningful and option filled life
definitely
where does said where does the
information come in I'm very curious
have the relationship to information
plays into all of this right well this
is a this is where the the fear factor
comes in you are talking about
mid-eighteen you know there's Mexico
that has a lot of drug war violence
going on of course the Middle East is a
perennial a bad reputation place to
travel to but keep in mind that
information is something that can work
against you or work for you and these
days information is everywhere when I
when I left to travel the United States
20 years ago I was actually more afraid
of the United States than in in 1994
then I'm afraid of any place in in 2014
simply because they're pre World Wide
Web I didn't know what to expect I had
no examples I've been in Kansas which is
not you know in sort of bullseye and
middle-class circles I didn't have a lot
of friends traveling full-time and so I
didn't really have anything to compare
to now if you're if you're a successful
person with the money to do it and and
the physical capacity to do it you can
go online and and not only can you can
you realize that people are traveling in
Mexico they're traveling in Colombia
they're traveling in Egypt and in Israel
in other parts of the world where you
think that might be dangerous you
realize that there's there's family
bloggers out there who are traveling
with five kids to these places or
traveling with a diabetes problem or
with physical handicaps or with
you know money they've made on a job
that has a fraction of what most people
make you know people who've simply
decided to become wealthy and time
regardless of the fact that they work as
park rangers or exotic dancers or
maintenance men and so that that
information you can if you get past I
guess media exists in a in a Man Bites
Dog world they're gonna talk about
explosions and revolutions and bad
things around the world and so much of
what we understand in fact there's that
famous phrase you know war is is God's
Way of teaching Americans geography
that's so horrible and so true and so
because Americans are so insular our
international understanding is really
pegged to major world events that don't
really represent day to day life in the
towns of these towns around the world so
if you can look past the panic-driven
Man Bites Dog tenner of media and
realized that Mexico is actually a giant
country and that the drug violence is
very isolated and if there are ways to
travel in in a very safe way in a very
inexpensive way then suddenly Mexico
becomes this amazing and very close way
to travel my my sister is a college
professor in north-central Kansas and
she they she and her family took a
little there's a big mexican-american
community in Kansas and they just took
the local Mexican minivan now down to
Fresno Mexico and just a family of four
and they've traveled for next to nothing
in an amazing way for their teenage sons
in to a part of the world that people
assume is full of drug violence right
and that was just taking a minivan from
five blocks so you know away from where
they live and so that information
realizing that the big picture news
media information is always gonna be
panic driven it's always gonna be you
know man and bites dog and so the more
you get to the specific information and
think hmm you know I'm 37 years old I'm
looking to take a sabbatical from my job
I live in Virginia
and I like to drink beer well
within 30 minutes you can find somebody
who's from a very similar life situation
who's doing what you're doing and again
even if I mean there's I mean there's
people who are blind who are who are
travelling for years at a time there
there are people with with major
impediments and if you're able-bodied
and you have a little money socked away
there's really nothing stopping you
except your own fear which is sometimes
tied to your ideas of money or your
ideas of what the world is like which is
pegged to information right a grid what
what type of sites or resources would
you recommend to people who are trying
to find comparable folks let's just say
people who will help them alleviate
their fear of travel or just in general
what type of online resources do you
recommend well Google for one I mean if
you just google you know thirty
five-year-old years old two kids one
year of travel then odds are you'll find
twenty blogs of people in that
demographic who are doing just that so
it's so really be be unabashed and very
specific about googling you know your
fears or your demographic and just see
who like you is is out traveling the
world there's a lot of great traveller
communities I've been affiliated with
boots and allcom since the very
beginning of vagabonding and part of
their mo is just sort of creating
community and and and support for people
and they have they have blogs and
resources on their site and there's
other travel communities as well and you
know what you you and boots and all is
well we'll put the links to everything
in the show of course in the show notes
for those people listening but it's
boots the letter n allcom right yeah Bo
TS n ALL calm and and they've been
operating out of Portland Oregon for
years and have just quietly been doing
very this the nice work of reassurance
and saying oh so you so you're worried
about it and around the world flight
well here's what around the house
around the world flights look you know
you're worried about a certain situation
you know here's here are some resources
for that and and they're not alone I'm
most familiar with them because we've
we've been we've sort of shared a
similar mission for a long time
but there are big communities of
travelers who who are happy to help and
and sort of help newbies feel better
about these prospects of long-term
travel yeah they're all over I remember
one that was very helpful to me in the
beginning was virtual tourist dot-com
and that I was with the site for a long
time and then the 4-hour workweek came
out and I ended up becoming friends much
in the same way that I reached out to
you I became friends with the founder of
virtual tourist and so I'm now actually
involved with a site of his called
trippy which is just trippy calm as
people would expect but it's it's
effectively community of of open
questions and you can follow specific
locations right so if you're interested
in whether it's San Francisco Buenos
Aires Spain MIDI in whatever all of the
questions that come up for instance I'm
just I'm just taking a quick look here
and you can that you can pose any
question you want
but you know what's the steepest place
you've ever been in you know country X
the what where is the best rock climbing
in San Francisco which is generally
going to be extremely inexpensive you
know what are the best online tools for
group vacation planning so if you're if
you're a family or multiple families so
like you said there there are many
different options speaking of Technology
how have how have different services
like whether it's couchsurfing or even
say Airbnb or anything else really these
collaborative consumption companies
changed travel for you and and perhaps
there are older examples but you
mentioned that your your tea your taking
a trip before we started recording and
you're doing a home swap is that is a
would you mind perhaps elaborating on
how some of those options work those
that you're familiar with because I
think that many people who consider
travel think in terms of one of their
main expenses being staying in a hotel
right and I'd love for you to to share
any of your thoughts on that
yeah well it's shifted the way the
travel world works in in in some ways
that are delightfully convenient and in
some ways that are a little bit strange
I think that technology is one of these
double-edged swords that in some ways
has turn us into insufferable
micromanagers on the road can you
elaborate on that yeah well I'll start
with the negative okay you know I I the
travel culture which I started in which
was 20 years ago but really my more
international traveler travels are more
like 15 years ago it's about showing up
in town and knowing that when you get
there
the unexpected awaits you that you that
you're gonna walk to the hotel district
you may have a guidebook with some hotel
recommendations but you're gonna shop
for your hotel you're not gonna find a
deal online you're gonna walk in there
you're gonna see the room you're gonna
haggle because in in in all throughout
Asia you know basically anyplace outside
of the industrial world prices are up
for grabs and and haggling in person is
so much more gives you so much more
leverage than haggling online because
you can go in look at the room and
physically leave if the owner doesn't
give you a price that you're that you're
into and so these days it has become so
convenient not always a bad thing but it
has become so convenient that people
just assume that the best deals to be
had are the ones online and then pretty
soon you've locked in your traveling for
six weeks and you know where you're
sleeping every night in advance and it
really compromises the flexibility of
travel and and the serendipity of being
inspired by a place and thinking I'm
gonna stay here for a few days or wow I
just met this traveler who told me about
this great place up in the mountains and
I'm not gonna go to Varanasi I'm gonna
go up into the Himalayas and spend my
time there
this technologically enhanced
micromanaging cuts into that stand and
dippity in a certain way
and it also connects us to home and and
again it's a two-edged thing social
media and the constant connectivity that
comes with smartphones for example
allows us to really find things that we
couldn't find before but it cuts into
the idea of wandering around and finding
things by surprise finding things
organically and letting letting it
destination reveal itself to us on its
own terms instead of sort of finding
that place as a consumer before we get
there and a lot of technologies have
eliminated things like loneliness and
boredom which sounds good and is good to
a certain extent but loneliness and
boredom can lead you to those moments
that that sort of force you into a new
version of yourself they force you to be
more extroverted they totally read
totally agreed they force you to read
the local newspaper instead of you know
looking through your facebook feet right
and so that's that is what we're up
against with this technological these
technological advances and I don't want
to be the grumpy older traveler because
I remember being being 20 and listening
to these you know baby boom era hippies
sort of lectured me on how travel used
to be you know back at a time when
telephone answering machines and credit
cards were seen as this decadent form of
Technology and and so I know that there
are younger travelers who don't know
anything but the constant connectivity
of travel but unplugging is important
and we can talk more about that if you
want and we can also talk about the
pluses and there I have many recent
examples about how technology have
helped this recent home exchange is just
a longtime friend who lives in Brooklyn
she's a writer and she wants a quiet
place I have 30 acres in Kansas and so I
get an awesome
pad in Brooklyn for a week and she gets
a quiet farm in Kansas for a time and
the positives you mentioned or alluded
to the positives I definitely want to
delve into the importance of
disconnecting yeah I think it becomes
somewhat especially living in Silicon
Valley but have some thoughts there as
well but what would you say how would
you expand on the the recent positive
positives or positive examples
you know we'll you mentioned Airbnb and
couchsurfing I think in places and more
expensive places like Europe you know
the hostel was your go-to it was where
if you wanted to save money you would go
to the to the youth hostel and it was a
great place to meet people you get a
cheap bed you went you you would forego
a few amenities but you would hang out
in the hostel well I went to Amsterdam
this summer I teach I teach a writing
course in Paris every summer and my
sister and my nephew came and visited me
and we wanted to go see Amsterdam and
using Airbnb I was able to get a full
cottage a 15 minute train ride outside
of central Amsterdam for about half the
price as a hostel for three people in
the center of Amsterdam so instead of
staying at somewhat rungy hostel in the
red-light district we were staying in
this little town filled with windmills
and we had our own house to ourselves
and we could just walk down the street
and get groceries and so there but that
was an Airbnb hookup couchsurfing is a
similar has similar benefits it just
allows you to break out of not only that
old hotel set of assumptions but also
out of the hostel set of assumptions the
idea that the cheapest option in any
place is going to be a hostel especially
traveling in groups for the three of us
if I'd been alone maybe I maybe the the
cottage wouldn't have been as cheap as
the hostel but with three of us where
you're getting hostel one bed at a time
we just got the perfect place to stay
through Airbnb and so those services and
even social media even going on Facebook
or Twitter and and I'm not a big
believer of tweeting while you travel I
think that that really puts you into
this home mindset and it pulls you out
of the place where you are and the point
of travel is experiencing what's before
your eyes and not what's coming across
your social media feed but before your
travel before one's travels I'm a big
fan of throwing throwing out a tweet or
a Facebook post that says hey look I'm
gonna be in this place what are some
suggestions and that is something that
didn't exist ten years ago and is not
tied to a business or social networking
thing
wipe Airbnb in couchsurfing but it could
just be that your buddy from high school
has a friend who's in the military in
Germany and they have an ex-girlfriend
who lives in Stockholm and suddenly you
have a place to stay through very random
circumstances and so that kind of it's
it's the old model of sitting in the
hostel or sitting in a guest house or a
bar in an exotic part of the world
talking to the six travelers who are
there with you and then giving you
advice on points further down the road
that principle has been taken to social
media and through networking that's
another way that technology has allowed
that that that old hostel room is
actually killed at the literal hostel
room where people are now staring at
their phones in the hostel room but it
is it has expanded the virtual hostel
room we're instead of talking to the six
travelers you're with physically you can
be talking to 600 travelers through your
networks who might have some good advice
for you know agreed and the touch on the
disconnection point I think that I think
that social media and being online while
traveling if the objective of travel is
to gain some introspection have unique
experiences and come back better than
when you left in some way is very
dangerous and at least speaking for me
personally the laptop is a portal to
many different things and it's it's very
common at least for if I'm speaking from
my personal experience and looking at
many of my friends who's whose
professional lives are based on
computers they look at a laptop they
look at their smartphone they look at
their desktop computer for work which is
most the vast majority of them who are
managing email using Basecamp or other
online services to manage business it is
it is a it's very easy to use Twitter or
Facebook socially as a gateway drug and
you're only one tab away from from from
going right back into your your old
routine
and it's extremely easy and seductive
like you said because of the convenience
to travel abroad and I know many people
who do this unfortunately I don't see
the point but they will take a laptop go
overseas stay at a hotel that could just
as easily be the Four Seasons in any
major city in the United States and they
come back and they really haven't
they've changed time zones but their
mind your experience hasn't changed more
than perhaps what they had for lunch
while they were broad which is a real
shame and so when when I've taken these
when I've taken sabbaticals which are
typically because I feel like I need to
reassess my priorities and gain some
perspective on things that are hard to
assess when you're down in the weeds
right when you're when you're deflecting
bullets and and dodging problems and
putting out fires looking at your email
inbox it's very hard to step back and
look at the larger picture of your life
and goals and whatnot from a 30,000 foot
view that for instance when I went to I
went to Bali to Indonesia for the first
time and took 30 days off of computer
phone and calendar basically - like you
said move from the micromanaging of my
daily experience to the extreme opposite
for me at least which was pretty much
pure serendipity and forcing myself to
rather than feel comfortable and
convenient to feel as uncomfortable as
possible at least when you consider how
routinized life becomes this even if
you're especially if you're kind of
optimizing for efficiency right it's
very easy to become trapped in systems
of your own making where you're like
well fantastic my per hour output is fit
is wonderful and doing all these new
things I'm taking on new projects and
then you step back and you realize wow I
well just be a cyborg running you know
running in all these systems so this is
a very long meandering
servation but i think that even if your
only goal and i don't think this is a
crass goal but even if your only goal
were to improve your professional life
especially if you run your own company
taking a month off the grid is perhaps
the best way to do it because you have
to set up systems that will persist
after you get back if you're taking
three days to go to Amsterdam you don't
need to do that a week off you can
probably come back and still rescue
things but a month off completely off
the grid and I was available for
emergencies via phone by my assistant or
other people they had to call the office
at the bahasa Indonesian language school
and then find their way to me
you really have to I think think about
the bigger questions that are easy to
avoid by by keeping your hands full with
busy work but anyway long long sort of
preachy observation but I really think
that you know the less you feel you can
go without your smartphone the greater
the value of going without your
smartphone yeah well this is this is an
old conversation the first person to do
this in in the technological age was was
actually JP Morgan when the telegraph
was invented he went to Egypt and I
forget exactly it was it was a little
over a hundred years ago and his
companions talked about how he was in
Egypt but not really because he was
always he spent his whole time in Egypt
attending to business
it was exactly it was like the turn of
the previous century version of what you
just explained it was him in a hotel
room you know attending to his business
technical technology basically the
Telegraph which is seems very primitive
in retrospect prevented you know JP
Morgan from actually being in Egypt he
may as well have not left home and so
this is an old problem in fact travelers
of previous generations have complained
that sailboats that steamships were
compromising travel in ways that
sailboats didn't in the Roman era the
you know the technology of roads was
changing the way travel was experienced
George Orwell talked about how
we're changing the way that that travel
was experienced in in trains when you
think about was the technology that
allowed you to travel so quickly
compared to how you previously could
that you could maintain a business
relationship of sorts while you were
traveling I don't think there's that
there's a silver bullet that can keep
you from being a slave to your
smartphone when you travel it's hard and
as you edit as you mentioned there are
some things that you have to maintain
back home if you're traveling for more
than a couple of weeks to an extent it's
a lot about self discipline there's
something to be said for physically not
taking your smartphone with you which is
something I don't do when I travel I use
the Internet right yeah absolutely I
make it I make it harder so I don't have
a data plan that that generally allows
me to get international coverage so okay
I can't use the phone yeah and this pays
off in tangible ways there's been recent
research that having a vacation that is
actually a vacation and this isn't about
vagabond this is about vacations is
important for your creative mind it's
important for your brain that having a
cessation of obsessing on your creative
life will allow your brain to work in
ways that will give that will make you
more creative so even if you go if you
travel to Amsterdam or Bangkok or the
the Andes for a week and you're
constantly attached to your smartphone
in some ways it could be less
advantageous to the creative life of
your business or your career then if you
just let go because if you let go of
that constant stream to the information
the micromanaging then your brain is
working in the same way that it was back
home and part of the gifts of travel is
your brain and your emotions and
everything is working in a new way and
your brain actually that obsessive part
of your brain is resting but it's a it's
actually working in its own way and and
this is actually scientific information
the New York Times reported on it about
a week ago that you actually come back
if you can unplug if you can actually
immerse yourself in a new place and turn
off that obsessive part of your business
brain then you can come back and your
mind will gift you with with with
creative
ideas and insights that it didn't have
if you had spent your whole time in the
Andes or Amsterdam or Bangkok obsessing
on those very business issues definitely
I'm sorry you took you took an inhale
you feel it sounded like I interrupted
you well there's one more point I was
gonna make is that it's sort of it's
sort of this ties into the idea of time
wealth that sometimes these days this
new generation has a way of stealing
time wealth again it's not that new I
mean Plato complained about that that
written literacy was ruining people's
ability to memorize poetry right but now
this technology is so it's so immersed
in our lives that we can steal our own
time wealth by being hooked into virtual
experiences into our social media feeds
instead of the experiences that are
before us
you used a great phrase which is
optimizing for efficiency and just think
if you're gonna sit down to an Italian
meal in Italy are you gonna want to
optimize that meal for efficiency if
you're gonna hike for a week in the
Andes and the Machu Picchu reason are
you gonna want to make sure that that
hike is optimized for efficiency if
you're gonna be sitting on a beach you
know in Thailand or Brazil are you gonna
want to optimize that experience for
efficiency I think that that Italian
meal metaphor can apply to so much of
travel that of course you don't want to
make it more efficient you want to savor
every bit of it you want to be you want
to be you know eating tomatoes that were
in the ground two nights before and and
having just these very sensual tactile
experiences not just in not just food
experiences but just ideas of the
unexpected of unplugging yourself from
the life that you can predict the life
that you could consume and buy and
stumbling into experiences that catch
you by complete surprise and I don't
want to overuse the idea of the word
super serendipity but it's something
that is at risk when we can't unplug and
and the gifts of serendipity are not
just you know actually you can stumble
into a bad experience as easily as you
can stumble into a good experience but
it's it's the it's the misadventures or
the unexpected good experiences that
actually change you
you know to the core of your being in a
way that those pre-planned experiences
don't and so if you can't unplug you're
robbing yourself of that aspect of your
time wealth you're making to extend this
metaphor you're making an optimized
efficiency out of an Italian meal in
every sense of the word
and it's hard to break away from but in
the vagabonding sense it's essential you
know you're gonna be selling yourself
short if you can if you can't stop
micromanaging and optimizing for
efficiency and the more you think about
those phrases in the context of the best
parts of travel the the more you realize
that you really have to throw you know
the jargon the efficiency jargon of
daily life out the window and just throw
yourself open to the travel experience
definitely and what you just one thing
that I think about a lot and part of my
motivation for traveling oftentimes and
you don't have to travel over overseas
to achieve this but I find the the the
change of scenery to be very helpful for
resetting is to focus on appreciation as
opposed to achievement and I'm very
type-a always have been and it's
competitive and then those can sometimes
really reinforce themselves and in good
but often destructive ways and when I go
abroad I think food is a fantastic lens
actually use not not just metaphorically
but to really focus on slow long meals
is I think one of the greatest gifts you
can give yourself and that was one of
the one of the experiences that I
brought back after my my nine months in
Argentina which was supposed to be four
weeks as these things often turn out
with the really long dinners you know a
couple bottles wine a bunch of friends
of course they have the you know
padishah and the incredible meats of of
Argentina but putting aside the fact
that they're famous in South America for
being unproductive putting that aside
the the long meals with with larger
groups of friends was something that I
brought back with me to the US and that
I try to do it
once a week or once every two weeks the
the other observation I want to make for
folks because I really was
well no forget was I think once once a
computer addict always a computer addict
just to kind of borrow from hey a you
know once an addict always an addict and
you have to manage that I think one of
the easiest ways to manage that is to
not rely on self-discipline what I mean
by that is when I took my trip in 2004
which which some people know began with
a one-way ticket to London and no
planned itinerary no planned return date
I didn't take my laptop I did and I knew
I couldn't take my laptop because I
would default to using it and what that
meant was at the time and there are many
different ways to do this now but I had
go to my PC installed on a computer at
home and if I wanted to use my laptop so
to speak I would have to go into an
internet cafe and which which is not
generally one of my favorite experiences
it's pretty did they're usually dingy
it's it's just not an experience I enjoy
which is entirely the point I wanted to
make it inconvenient and unpleasant to
engage in sort of masturbatory computer
use you know and I think that it's it's
very easy to default to that because you
can always find something on the
internet right whether it's and you
couldíve airy easily go to Morocco and
then end up sitting on your laptop
watching the stupidest cat videos on
YouTube for hours a day like because
that's what the internet optimizes for
it optimizes for clicks and views and
everything else that can be
commercialized generally speaking so you
know don't even enter don't walk through
the door if you don't want that to
happen so when in when possible to
change your environment and remove
things that facilitate bad behavior as
opposed to trying to rely on willpower
which i think is very very fallible the
you mentioned creativity and I wanted to
ask you about that because I really
really enjoy your writing and and I
don't say that lightly
not that I'm the ultimate connoisseur in
writing but I think that a lot of
writing is very very bad and ii-i've
loved your writing and enjoyed it for a
very long time
Thanks of course yeah it's it's had a
huge impact on my thinking and not not
moreover my actual behavior and way of
living so the I want to talk about the
the concept of a staycation are there
times for for creativity and let's just
use writing as an example do you find
that you can replicate some of the
benefits of travel in what people might
refer to as a staycation yes yeah and
this goes back to something that we were
talking much earlier in the conversation
about decluttering emotionally you
talked about the idea but I think you
used the word portfolio to describe
something but I think I think
vagabonding the principles of Vagabond
apply to life in non-travel ways and it
it's it's been used as a text in social
studies class and it's sort of about
another sign into something else we were
talking about earlier you were talking
about something that sort of constitutes
what some people call the beginner's
mind which is part of the excitement of
traveling definitely is that we we get
stuck into being experts in the in and
online resources allow us to be sort of
dilettante experts in everything you
know we can we can suddenly know a
little bit about everything when in fact
the beginner's mind is is is one of the
most emotionally daunting and exciting
parts of travel where you just allow
yourself to be a child again and in fact
I have some quotes in vagabonding
talking about how you go to a new city
and you're as dumb as a five-year-old
you know you can hardly read you know
you don't know it's dangerous to cross
the street you know that this is a gift
of travel is that it allows you to to
have the vulnerability of being very
young but also
excitement a very being very young in
the discovery of being very young and
sometimes for all of the research you do
back home the coolest part of showing up
in in Bangkok or Buenos itis or you know
Cape Town is just smelling the place you
know or or going and into not into a
tourist place but into a supermarket and
realizing how different everything is
and it's it's that beginner's mind
it's that wonder of childhood stuff and
that can become a you can turn into a
cheesy metaphor but it's a real thing
it's the it's the beginner's mind that
allows you to engage in a new way and so
I think that ties into the idea of of
creativity and mistake ation which is a
silly word for what is a great idea
which is taking that beginner's mind
taking that travel mindset which I
talked about at the end of vagabond in
the idea of coming home and treating
your neighbors as exotic tribesmen back
home and one thing and actually one
thing I'd love to talk to you about is
the idea of appreciation versus
achievement because there's limits to
achievement I mean you've been it's been
four hour workweek came out what 7 2007
yes seven years ago and I think there's
you know there's an extent to which that
ongoing success can be as meaningless as
ongoing lack of success and then that
you have to have a relationship with
that to realize that appreciation
becomes more important than achievement
because there comes a point at which
that you've achieved your goals and now
what you know definitely um and so I
think it's evening as a linear way of
thinking which is very American and
important and I'm a big believer in that
but appreciation is that more Eastern
circular way of thinking of being able
to savor what you do have and balancing
that with your achievements and and so
that goes back in ties into the
creativity the idea of coming back home
and I own a house on thirty acres of
land in Kansas and that that's no
accident I'm close to my family but it's
also really really cheap and instead of
living in a fashionable part of a big
city I can I mean what's happening right
now is an example of it I'm doing a I'm
gonna go live in Brooklyn for a week and
and
and do a little home exchange and I have
the option of living in for short
periods of time anywhere well at the
same time saving money and really
building a relationship to a place which
is my quiet thirty acres in a sparsely
populated part of north central Kansas
and I am extraordinarily creative there
not just because it's quiet but because
I can have sort of a quieter sense of
discovery sort of a walking space
neighbors pace sense of discovery in the
place where I live this is another one
of the Silver Bullet things you were
talking about how you enjoyed my writing
and it is so tortured sometimes to write
well you know I'm very familiar one
beautiful smooth reading logical
inspirational paragraph of prose is the
process of a day of labor and
self-loathing so just because I have
this wonderful place to write and and
that might in create creativity is
enhanced by by marrying my travel
mindset to my home doesn't mean that I
just am sitting at my desk laughing and
glee with my glass of wine writing
brilliant prose it doesn't get easier
but you know I guess it enables that
creative project orchard process to be
fruitful in a way that perhaps it
wouldn't have been otherwise I don't
know I don't know I know that you have a
very annie dillard said that a schedule
is a net for catching days and I think
that you you're a believer in being very
disciplined about having a writing
schedule I'm not very disciplined but
somehow it works anyway well just like
just because I'm a believer doesn't mean
I'm a fantastic practitioner right but I
think for folks who are wondering what
it's like to be a writer for most people
now I should maybe caveat that with the
observation that I have extreme jealousy
slash anger sometimes towards extremely
good journalists who have daily or
weekly deadlines because many of them to
my to migrate up
disagree that writer's block even exists
and they say I don't have the luxury of
writer's block I need to kick out 1500
words a day and they're exceptionally
good at it and it's just infuriating
because my experience with writing is
number one it has not gotten easier
generally people ask me like oh well
after the third book you know it must
just get easier eat some like actually
it just gets harder and harder because I
have to I feel like I have to ensure
that I'm not repeating myself but the
the the most accurate sort of portrayal
of my experience of writing is
adaptation hmm and my god and and I
actually I think Nicolas Cage is amazing
in it but the movie the movie is weird I
I read the screenplay first but just the
idea that you sit down you're like okay
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this new
like you know god I should really wash
my face you know like I should just she
did a doughnut I need to relax before I
start writing to all of these like you
will at least I you know I'm Rand okay I
could never really I don't know if it's
ion or Ann but anyway let's just say
Iran had a book called how to write I
think it was how to write nonfiction and
there's a portion called the white
tennis shoes and I remember the white
tennis shoes is refers to the fact that
if you sit down to write and there's a
pair of white tennis shoes with a little
blemish on it you will you will convince
yourself that you need to you need to
clean those shoes before you write and
that a writer will do anything to avoid
writing so that's that's my general
experience I feel like a schedule or at
least a plan helps to even if you don't
fulfill that plan for me it's it's that
and I think this is actually a Winston
Churchill quote where he said that in
effect you know a plan is important not
because you're going to follow the plan
but for the planning itself and I find
that having a plan for writing decreases
my anxiety associated with writing which
helps me to write even if I don't
execute that plan perfectly but what
would it what is your writing process
like and I have you know have some
additional questions about travel of
course but
and vagabonding I should say rather but
what does your writing process look like
when do you typically sit down to write
and why well it's funny that you
mentioned the Nicolas Cage character and
adaptation as something you can relate
to because that's like the least
glamorous depiction of a writer you know
and you're gonna compromise the people's
romantic conception of you as a writer
and and and my process is possibly even
worse I think because I don't know I
think in there's there's different
neuroses attributed to writer and and
mine is maybe a little bit
obsessive-compulsive that sometimes I
could be the guy who writes two hours
before breakfast every day and sometimes
I am but sometimes I'm the guy who
writes for 14 hours and and is it most
fruitful at hour 13 and so you know my
if I wrote a writers handbook and I
teach writing and I try to instill you
know discipline and ideas of discipline
in my students because that's important
because people can over romanticize
writing and think about the muse
visiting them and in fact you need to be
the one who creates this but in practice
I'm sort of a bad example that there's
some days we're all just sort of be just
frustrated with myself I'll have my spot
on the white shoes problem I actually
bought the freedom app you know the
freedom app the internet connection oh
the freedom app I thought you said the
freedom app I was very excited yes no
the freedom app is cool I agree yeah and
it's just one of those things where
despite my good intentions sometimes you
know my monkey brain goes back to the
internet and I just have to you know be
my own mother and discipline myself I
wrote a screenplay in 12 days earlier
this month Wow and so that's an example
of it was really a it was sort of a
pulpy b-movie screenplay that I did for
fun just because I had this idea and I I
would compromise my happiness if I
didn't suddenly write this movie that
was about designs ambe's and giant
dinosaur attacks and I think that was
almost part of resting certain parts of
my intellectual brain and
just delightful to write a really pulpy
story but it was interesting it's like I
keep teaching myself lessons when I
wrote something low stake when I wrote a
b-movie you know a monster movie earlier
this month it gave me such an
interesting creative perspective of mine
on my own processes and the importance
of just getting work out there but I was
I was able to write 90 pages in 12 days
whereas sometimes I can be tortured
tortured over a 1,500 word article so I
think there's something you know worthy
and the idea of you know an lamotte's
idea of shitty first drafts of getting
the word the words on the page Kurt
Vonnegut said that there's two types of
writers there's supers and bashers as
super oh I'm so glad you're bringing
this up yeah please go into this you're
familiar with the concept I am but I
want you to I want you to explain it
because this is Sookie
yeah well swoop errs tend to be people
who will blast through their first draft
and then they'll spend days if not weeks
working on draft number two and number
thirteen and number 67 until they get it
right whereas bashers they go sentence
by sentence and by the time page one is
done then paid then paragraph one has
been written rewritten ten times and by
the time they finish what they're
working on be it 1500 words or 30,000
words it's pretty much done they're not
going to do a whole lot of rewrites but
that process has taken you know 20 times
as long as a swooper will take and these
are both legitimate creative methods and
and he suggests that maybe women tend to
be supers and men tend to be bashers and
that might be statistically true but
I've met you know male swimmers and and
and female bashers and they're both
creative ways I am a basher through and
through I am as well and I think I think
of the two I've never been a super so I
don't know how it feels but I have to
imagine that being a basher it's just
the most torturous process of
self-loathing and doubt I just I it's
because there are days I don't know if
you've experienced this but they'll be
like okay great I'm going to try to
knock out whatever it is a few pages
and I will just agonize over the first
two paragraphs for in an hour it's so
god it's just like gives me anxiety of
than thinking about it but yeah anyway I
apologize this is serving as a therapy
session for me oh no it's it's actually
and hopefully people in our audience can
can take part in this but it's I'm in
the exact same situation that the last
third of a story or even a book is the
easiest to write because I have the
first two-thirds to show that I'm not a
complete incompetent you know and that I
have I in my office I have different you
know writing awards and articles about
myself to sort of remind me that I'm not
a complete incompetent
but that blank page that the generations
of writers have talked about is a real
kind of anxiety and getting started and
I have a really bad combination which is
that I'm a basher but I'm also an
optimist and I and I think that if I
completely gave way to self-loathing and
pessimism that I would just throw
something horrible out and then and then
I would have something but I'm just yeah
I just have this blank page anxiety
coupled with with the optimism that I
that I that I think I can do good it
just makes it that much harder to get
started because III just can't I know
that something is gonna be good but for
some reason that first step is somehow
at odds with with with my optimism so
it's it's a weird thing and I'm actually
relieved to hear that you struggle with
the same thing oh yes struggles I think
a very generous light were both
successful authors something know
hopefully people take take some solace
in that the I think I think matters are
not helped by the fact that I've tried
for years to change my writing schedule
so that I get good synthesis I tend to
differentiate between research and and
synthesis sort of gathering up all of my
material and then putting it into prose
it doesn't help matters that I've tried
to become a morning writer and I have
friends who do this for the wake
really early and they kick out good pros
in the morning I've never been good at
it so I tend to get started in the
middle of the night when it's
pitch-black outside and so I have those
moments of acute anxiety I might as well
be in solitary confinement in you know
in a basement so that probably doesn't
help my psychological state much but who
knows maybe some good has come of it the
what are you what are some of your
favorite books or articles on writing
itself or just commentary these could be
authors who have written about it but
I'm just I'm looking for it for things
myself quite frankly to read you
mentioned Anne Lamott I think bird by
bird is a fantastic book but what would
a what are some of your favorite books
or commentaries on writing well this is
funny because I thank you for supporting
the sponsors this show 99designs
which is your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related go to
99designs comm forward slash tim to see
the projects that I've put up including
the mock-ups and drafts of the book
cover for the 4-hour body ex-officio
ex-officio and I go way back
ex-officio dot-com forward slash Tim you
can see the clothing that I've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries
including the underwear by the way
that's about half of my underwear drawer
right now ex-officio comm forward slash
Tim you can also see the viral video
that I put out which shows you how to
travel the world with ten pounds or less
as always you can subscribe to this
podcast on iTunes and you can find all
of the links and resources from this
episode as well as every other episode
by going through 4-hour workweek comm
forward slash podcast spell it all out
or you can go to 4-hour work week calm
and just click on podcast feedback if
you have feedback I would love your
thoughts anything at all who you'd like
to see on this show ping me on twitter
at t-- ferrus that's Twitter com /t fer
Riss or on facebook at facebook.com
forward slash
Tim Ferriss with two R's and two S's and
until next time thank you for listening
you